ah
desde hace más de siete décadas
palestina está buscando ser un estado
reconocido pero el camino está lleno de
tropiezos israelí-palestina están
condenados a entenderse como vecinos
pero desde los 90 con la intifada todos
los acuerdos de paz han fracasado por
uno u otro motivo el último esfuerzo
viene de la mano de la administración
trump con el acuerdo del siglo favorable
a israel en sus políticas de
asentamientos pero si palestina no es un
estado no es sólo culpa de israel hay
diferencias a nivel internacional
regional y entre los propios palestinos
países como eeuu y alemania no reconocen
a palestina como estado y la liga árabe
tiene diferencias a la hora de la
cuestión palestina también los
palestinos están divididos políticamente
cisjordania pertenece al fatah y gaza al
movimiento hamás ahora además algunos
países árabes han normalizado su
relación con israel y palestina' piensa
que tendrá menos aliados en el futuro
[Música]
karabaj es una nación no reconocida
desde los años 90 ha estado a la sombra
de armenia y ahora tras una corta guerra
vuelve a las manos de azerbaiyán
hablamos de territorios acerías
controlados desde 1994 por armenia
armenia entregó ahora hace días
azerbayán 7 localidades que formaban
parte de la región de nagorno karabaj lo
hace en cumplimiento del acuerdo del
alto el fuego firmado el pasado 9 de
noviembre una paz alcanzada con la
mediación de rusia
el acuerdo establece un calendario para
la devolución a azerbayán de una serie
de territorios que han permanecido bajo
control armenio y también con población
armenia desde la guerra del 94 las
autoridades de nagorno karabaj han
asegurado que ya se han desplazado las
propiedades de más de 2.000 residentes
en esas siete localidades cedidas a
azerbaiyán y que los afectados van a
recibir pronto alojamiento temporal
[Música]
el sahara occidental es considerada la
última colonia de áfrica desde que
españa el antiguo poder colonial dejó el
territorio en 1975 esta región estaba en
disputa entre el reino de marruecos y el
frente polisario de liberación aunque en
este momento marruecos controla el 75
por ciento del territorio las naciones
unidas- no reconocen la soberanía de
esta región para ninguna de las dos
partes pero la unión africana sí
reconoce el derecho a la
autodeterminación del pueblo saharaui y
ha permitido que sea uno de esos estados
miembros desde 1991 ha habido un cese al
fuego entre marruecos y polisario pero
esto amenaza con romperse después de que
activistas saharauis acosan a marruecos
de una operación militar el fin de
semana pasado y esto podría desencadenar
en un conflicto a gran escala después de
décadas de conflictos y de disputas
territoriales se calcula que unos
100.000 refugiados saharauis viven en
campamentos en el desierto y en
condiciones muy precarias
[Música]